Matt Zab cousin knows the highs and lows
of an addiction to gambling it's
affected my mental health affected the
way I looked at the world and there was
a a Time towards the end where I was
suicidal and did make an attempt on my
own life and and that that's sort of
where it ends up for a lot of people
unfortunately
he now campaigns for a tightening of
existing laws around who how and when
people can place bets in an industry
that derives much of its wealth from a
minority of compulsive gamblers
I think there's very little
justification for promoting an industry
like this in its current form I think at
the moment you've got basically a
situation where about 86 of the profits
online are coming from five percent of
gamblers
more than half of betters use their
mobile devices to gamble three-quarters
of them 18 to 34 year olds using
multiple sites with sports betting
skyrocketing during the pandemic you
only need to look at England's Premier
League to see the prevalence and
prominence of the betting industry
Brentford is one of many teams whose
shirts are emblazoned with gambling
logos and many of the ads around the
game are for online betting companies
its owner made his fortune precisely as
a professional Gambler and Ivan Tony one
of its star players its Striker also
plays for England was recently banned
for eight months for breaching Football
Association rules on gambling
many leading clubs have agreed to stop
lucrative Match Day front of shirt
sponsorship deals with gambling
companies for mid-2026 the UK
governments also recently published a
review a white paper of gambling laws
for the digital age including maximum
Stakes for under 25 year olds and
affordability checks for online
customers but the reforms could be many
years away it's great to see that change
is coming but what we do see in the
white paper is that lots of the measures
proposed are subject to further
consultation and that's a concern just
because of the time it takes until those
consultations are complete and change
has happened and we won't see those
greater Protections in place
only one of the Dozen gambling companies
we contacted offered us a comment entain
that owns multiple big betting Brands
and platforms says it's in favor of
Regulation that ensures appropriate
protection to all players while
preserving the market
for matzob cousin meaningful change
needs to happen at a meaningful Pace to
protect vulnerable users from gambling
with their lives
Nev Barker Al Jazeera London